[Music]  yes miss Minaj darling you looking  fabulous first of all tell me about this  look the pressure of the Met Gala the  the look is Oscar de la Renta I'm very  excited and you know it's all about you  know being the bad guy I'm the bad guy  [ __ ] sound dress that the devil Nicki  Minaj bring in at Charlie to the Met  Ball steps  jeongmi can't wait for the album tell me  about when when yes now I can give you  some exclusive information the album  comes out on June 15 and it's called  Queen have you feeling a queen tonight I  do feel like a queen collaborations or  duets trios yeah I have a collab or two  that I'm excited about you've been to  the back gala before what happens inside  how do you throw down when we get inside  we just left off mingle really don't eat  anything and you know watch the  performance and leave  [Music]  [Applause]